top-five manias running wild I am Walter
Bernays yak
last week we took a look at the worst
but today we count down the top 5 best
WWE finishers I got some great feedback
from you guys on last week's episode and
if you want more wrestling related
videos make sure you keep letting me
know in the comments below on my twitter
at awesome underscore walter and
subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome Walter I'll
definitely be putting more wrestling
related videos on there soon it's
WrestleMania season with a 33rd edition
of the show of shows coming up on April
2nd now is a great time to talk about
everyone's favorite panda protecting
former Federation World Wrestling
Entertainment the finisher is a
wrestlers move that is supposed to put
away his or her opponent and most of the
time they win their match with it
there has been some awesome ones in the
long history of World Wrestling
Entertainment / the World Wrestling
Federation and some of these moves are
even more popular than the wrestlers
performing them all you ready these are
the top 5 BET WWE finishers number 5
Seth Rollins curb stomp this is a
personal favorite and it's been vain for
a few years now but I always thought it
was a great move and looked legit as his
opponent was down Rollins would run at
them jump and bury his foot in the back
of their head until they hit the ground
it wasn't a long way down to the mat but
man this thing looks effective
especially when Ron's would do it onto a
chair or harder surface Vincent's been
banned Rollins now uses the pedigree as
his finisher I guess it makes sense
considering his involvement with Triple
H but the banning of the curb stop never
really made much sense to me then was
like well I could see I could see Shane
doing this very easily to Stephanie when
they were kids like he had that vision
in his head Stephanie line throwing on
the ground and changed stomping her in
the back of the head and I'm like what
do you say what do I even say to that
nine children one of the marks of a good
finisher for any wrestler is the ability
to perform it on anyone Seth isn't a
small guy at all but compared to some of
the bigger
wrestlers on the roster he's not exactly
a giant he could do the curb stomp on
anyone no matter the size of the person
taking it in fact I think the wrestler
who took it the best was a bigger guy
Brock Lesnar took and sold that thing
perfectly he'd raised his head just a
bit before going down and the timing was
always great FINA always took a mean
curb stomp as well and Rob Van Dam had
at least one memorable one it was a
badass move that was genius in its
simplicity maybe down the road they'll
bring it back but until then it will be
myth number four
Evan borns airborne the shooting star
press was done before this and has been
done after this but it's never been done
quite as well as when Evan Bourne
performed the move for anyone who
doesn't know what a shooting star press
is Evan would climb to the top rope and
do a forward jumping backflip landing on
his laying opponent chest first
it was very over with the fans and still
look spectacular to this day even if the
bar has been raised with more complex
top rope finishers this always looks
flawless and nobody did it better the
most well-known person to use this move
before born was Billy Kidman
while it was impressive it was also kind
of crap
now Java the rarest of five full minutes
because Annie right here was driven
right to the temple of Java Guerrero
ugly sometimes
it was another previously banned moved
by WWE and this instance may have had
something to do with that Warren brought
it back with very positive results and
at his peak he became very popular for
performing the move I always like to
have been born and there was a moment
there for a few weeks where he was
starting to be pushed as a semi big deal
it didn't last too long but I was behind
him and it's a real shame how his foot
injury and other issues and did his WWE
career however he still wrestles on the
Indies and his airborne is tough to top
Neville's red arrow is definitely more
difficult to do but it doesn't look
quite as pretty or clean as born
stunning finisher
number three Stone Cold Steve Austin
Stone Cold Stunner this is quite
possibly the most well known finisher
WWE has ever had
cold stone cold would kick his opponent
in the midsection lock their head over
his shoulder and drop his butt down to
the mat it's a truly iconic maneuver
that was the top move of the top star in
the top era of the top company in
wrestling pop since Austin was arguably
the most popular superstar in the
history of wrestling this will have got
a lot of attention when he was the WWE's
number-one guy in the 90s it's such an
easy and often sudden move to hit but it
always felt special the crowd reaction
to a Stone Cold Stunner in the Attitude
Era we're something to see and hear
just this fun is seeing it Center was
how the stunner'd person took it
the rock is well-known for his
over-the-top way of doing so but my
favorite stunner take goes to sky with
Vince McMahon at the close second
you'd be hard-pressed to find a
wrestling fan who doesn't like the
stunner it's a fun move to see live or
on TV it's good to see Austin return to
TV to deliver one once in a while to an
unsuspecting victim and that's the
bottom line because stone cold said sir
number two Brock Lesnar's f5 from the
first second I saw this move in 2002
I've loved rock picks up his opponent in
a fireman's carry and spins them off his
shoulders with torque they crash into
the mat it's one of the coolest
finishers I've seen in WWE and the one I
imitated most as a kid I was at fiving
everybody as one of the older kids among
my cousin's everyone was fair game I'd
have five them in the pool on the
couches grasp forever teenage Walter was
bringing the pain I don't even have five
cousins that were bigger than me
I wasn't able to get the full rotation
they usually landed on me but it didn't
matter that's five fury pitch now this
is a move that showed off some strength
I love watching f5 bigger wrestlers
little wrestlers didn't matter they all
fell to this move tornadic nature I will
say when Brock first picked up Big Show
for the move it was one of the most
impressive feats of strength I ever saw
at that point it was incredible Brock
was unstoppable in this first year
tearing through everyone a true monster
I was a huge Hogan fan in those days and
seeing him there hug the Hulkster until
he bled from the mouth made me hold a
grudge against Lesnar for years even
when he turned face I hated him it
wasn't until years later that I started
coming around to rooting for him and
matches however I always loved that f5
what can you fi the shark there were a
lot of amazing finishers that I just
couldn't fit onto this list so before we
get to number one here are some
honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best WWE finisher is
I hate to be predictable but this really
has become the best finisher in WWE
somewhat similar to the Stone Cold
Stunner Randy Orton's RKO is famous for
being hit from out of nowhere or and
leaves his feet jumping high into the
air and grabbing his opponent's head he
pulls it all the way down to the surface
below while orange himself lands on his
back creating an even bigger impact it's
a move that has gotten more and more
popular over time but didn't blew up a
couple years ago with memes that were
impossible to escape Randy Orton a place
we've never seen before
we've seen DDP do the same move years
before Randy in WCW but Orden does it a
little bit differently make no mistake
the diamond cutter was a huge move that
was also very popular for its time
people love to see it however Orton
brought it up to the next level with his
uncanny athleticism he jumps into it
which makes the move that much bigger
and what everybody loves to see is when
he hits it unexpectedly counters into
the RKO are some of the coolest looking
highlight reel moments of modern WWE
[Applause]
just when you think you can't pull off
the more unique RKO Orton does it it's
the finisher that keeps on giving and
it's my number one best WWE finisher I
want to hear what you guys think what is
your favorite WWE finisher when you want
me to cover next in the show leave a
comment and let me know take a look back
at last week's video where we count down
the top 5 worst WWE finishers make sure
you check out awesome comics from
yesterday where we asked should that man
kill yes no yes no yes no yes no yes no
yes yeah also remember if you're
interested in more wrestling talk
subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome Walter follow
me on Twitter to take part in more polls
about what I'm a countdown in the future
the future I'm going to get back back to
the
[Music]
[Applause]
you